son éditeur lui avait demandé de
réaliser le voyage de ses rêves celui
qu'il n'avait jamais eu le temps
d'entreprendre et c'est au fil de la
loire que robert doisneau a choisi de
nous emmener de novembre 76 out 77
il a parcouru le fleuve de sa source
jusqu'à son embouchure un portraits
ciselés du cours d'eau et de ceux qui
l'animent
à travers plus de 70 clichés la loire
qu'il dessine en noir et blanc est un
tableau vivant qui remet toujours
l'homme dans son environnement un humain
dans un paysage
ça change complètement le regard et le
message dès que l humain est présent
dans le paysage c'est humain devient
l'élément principal de la photo donc il
ya quelque chose de fort qui traduit la
donc tout ce qu'on peut voir d'où
anneaux est un observateur patients qui
conserve une certaine distance vis-à-vis
de ces sujets il guette l'anecdote la
petite histoire ces photographies sont
souvent empreintes d'humour mais
également de nostalgie d'ironie et de
tendresse
passionné de pêche depuis l'enfance
l'artiste est comme chez lui dans les
méandres de la loire ces clichés ont été
éditées dans un livre intitulé la loire
journal d'un voyage